[Music]
okay no need to panic I got this choice
between hand soap or hand sanitizer the
hand soap it's bubbly smells pretty nice
especially that apricot cucumber scent
actually it smells pretty weird but a
good weird however Washington with soap
does take kinda long and then you have
to dry your hands off laying the hand
sanitizer on the other hand pun intended
it's way faster but it dries out your
skin what should I choose knowing the
difference between hand soap and hand
sanitizer isn't about which kills more
bacteria they're both effective anti
bacterial agents the difference really
comes down to which is a better
surfactant surfactants are compounds
that decrease surface tension in this
case the surfactant is disrupting the
attraction of liquid and solid molecules
on a surface which is your hand soap is
an excellent surfactant because it
disrupts this attraction by forming
spherical shells of soap around the
molecules called micelles if my terrible
2d drawing doesn't get the message
across these micelles are actual 3d
spherical structures soap is able to
form these micelles due to its molecular
properties a soap molecule has two
components a fatty acid chain which is
hydrophobic and a head group which is
positively or negatively charged making
it hydrophilic when exposed to a
non-polar substance say oil on a dinner
plate
the hydrophobic end becomes attracted to
the oil and the hydrophilic end faces
toward the water the micelles and
capture the oil molecules and are then
washed away down the drain this is the
exact same way soap removes bacteria
from your skin the soap first kills the
bacteria by lysine and open this
destroys the structure of the membrane
causing release of membrane lipids and
proteins all over your skin the soap
then forms micelles around these
components of bacteria and the micelles
get washed away
hand sanitizer on the other hand is a
terrible servant
it's just rubbing alcohol and glycerol
which forms this really effective anti
bacterial goo that's all well and good
but how does this pastie goo clean your
hands well it doesn't and sanitizer
kills bacteria by Lysa no 'pn the
bacterial membrane this spells out
bacterial components and now you have
dead bacteria smeared all over your hand
as well as dead skin cells and dirt
because well you're smearing dead
bacteria and dead skin cells all over
your hand duh and even if you were to
rinse your hands after using the hand
sanitizer the alcohol denatures the
bacterial proteins making them even more
sticky and clumped into your skin so the
water does very little to remove it this
is why we don't use alcohol to wash
dishes sure it would kill the bacteria
and sterilize the plates but then you'd
have this nasty layer of crusty proteins
and lipids on your dishes in summary
soap kills bacteria in the same way that
alcohol does the soap however actually
removes and cleans the dead bacteria by
capturing the components in micelles the
alcohol though an antiseptic just smears
the dead bacteria and proteins on your
skin so soap it is good to know if you
notice my bad acting you probably
noticed the shirt I was wearing you can
get one for yourself - the bad acting at
my merch shop the links in the
description below I'd also like to take
a second to thank my very generous
patrons who helped support this and
future videos as always thanks for
watching and stay tuned